-Guys, as you know, every week,
we like to bring you some
uplifting, creative videos,
whether they
come from quarantine
or just stuff
around the country.
It's time for
"What Are You Doing Wednesday."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ What are you doing
this Wednesday? ♪
♪ What are you doing
-Just in time for Halloween,
our first video
is kind of a scary one.
This guy's in his house.
Alone.
And hears some spooky music.
Check it out.
[ Organ playing ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
What?
[ Laughter continues ]
I love it's not just a cat.
It's a cat in, like,
some crazy outfit.
Like, what is the cat wearing?
[ Laughter ]
-Aww!
-Next up, you know those
inflatable tube dancing things
outside the car -- yeah.
-Right.
-Car dealerships.
Well, one family put up
one in the front yard
as a Halloween decoration,
and it got a lot of attention
from some of the local youth.
Take a look at this.
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's cute.
The kid was there for six hours.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, have you ever gone
paddleboarding?
-Yeah, yeah.
Just the other day.
[ Laughter ]
We gotta rehearse this banter.
For everyone who's
ever gone paddleboarding,
you realize why they call it
an exercise.
It's -- It's tough.
But anyway,
some people think it's, like,
a fun way to just --
I don't know --
vacation or something.
Anyway, check it out.
♪♪
The person in the back.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow! Look out, Scott.
They're...
-Now look at the person
in the front!
Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
Now the person in the back.
Come on.
You got it.
No, you don't got it.
There you go.
There you go, everybody!
That was
"What Are You Doing Wednesday."